Listen up, gentlemen.
You morons may have only let me win 11 games.
We suck. We're...
NOT GETTING MINNESOTA MIRACLE’D
BY THE F--KING EAGLES THIS—
year may be Jared’s last chance
before we replace him
with another cheap rookie.
I’m sorry, what?
I SAID I DON’T EVEN LOOK WHEN I THROW.
WOO-HOO! YEAH!
Settle down
I know everyone is depressed
because we’re a two seed
but we have to stick together.
Gilmore
what happens when we're
five seconds late to a meeting?
We get yelled at till we cry?
And Gronk
remember when you were
unhappy with the team?
PATRIOTS TRIED TO TRADE GRONK
AFTER THEY BROKE GRONK’S BODY.
And Josh Gordon, remem-
Oh right. We have no—
RECEIVERS MUST GET TACKLED
ON THE LAST PLAY OF THE—
game reminds me of the
1918 Dayton Triangles/Toledo Maroons game
where they had a secret—
weapon.
ANDY REID AFTER A BYE WEEK!!!
I HAVE TIME, BOYS!
HE’S BACK!
And yes
there’s stuff to worry about
like aging—
And Zeke
And the fact that
Bountygate clearly angered God
AND HURTING MY FRIEND THE FOOTBALL
BY THROWING IT TOO HARD.
BUT THIS IS OUR YEAR.
BIG NICK HERE TO DOUBLE DOINK EVERYONE!
- Oh Christ!
- Oh Muskrats!